as the violence in ukraine continues
there are about three million refugees
that have been forced from their homes
one family in las vegas going above and
beyond collecting supplies for those
struggling a world away sasha loftis
joining us tonight with their story
brian the father and daughter i spoke
with just want to do what they can to
help they've been gathering anything
they can to help those going through
unimaginable pain thousands of miles
away
these people really need help they do
shawn and iris hunt are on a mission to
make a difference
since russia's invasion on ukraine
started last month
the father and daughter have been
devastated and want to help in any way
they can from here in henderson
everybody's like oh donate
cash that's what they really need but
they're going to run out of blankets in
europe so they wrote up letters like
this and passed them around town asking
for blankets comforters and even warm
hats we're like can you hang this up in
your shop but even if you can't can you
put it up in your neighborhood in just a
few days they've gathered this pile of
supplies
and they're sending it all directly to
poland's shema show camp for ukrainian
refugees this is truly our chance to
make real and effective change
in this country and around the world
right now shawn and iris say the
generosity they've witnessed so far is
nothing short of amazing i'm really
proud of my kids and all the people who
have come to help out and they hope
their efforts to spread the word
will encourage others to do what they
can to help so many still struggling i
just hope more people stand up and stand
with ukraine
sean says he will ship boxes full of
supplies every few weeks as he can
afford the postage if you'd like to
donate we have more information right
now on our website
8newsnow.com brian